the number of covert cases is soaring
states are bringing back lockdowns
reinstating limits on gatherings
closing schools one million new cases
were reported in just six days
the virus is killing more than one
thousand people in america each day
against that backdrop another drug
company has announced it has made a
breakthrough in the hunt for a vaccine
moderna says its drug in early tests
shows
it's 94 effective we have a lot of work
ahead of us
knowing the vaccine is going to be
effective is great news but we still
need to
complete the regulatory process the
company hopes to have the first 20
million doses ready to go before the end
of the year
frontline workers and those most at risk
will be treated first
before there's a bigger roll out that's
led america's top covert expert to warn
people
they can't relax just yet the virus is
not going to stop and call a timeout
while things change the virus is just
going to keep going the process is just
going to keep going
this is something that just is now going
in the very very strong right direction
president donald trump who claimed that
last week's breakthrough announcement
was delayed until
after the election to damage him
politically
struck a different tone with the new
vaccine tweeting out that historians
should note that these great
breakthroughs were made
on his watch good afternoon
in delaware president-elect joe biden
laid out his plans to get the economy
up and running and insisted the trump
administration should work with him
to save lives more people may die
if we don't coordinate look
as my chief of staff ron claim would say
who
handled ebola the vaccine is important
it's of little use until you're
vaccinated
so how do we get the vaccine how do we
get over 300 million americans
vaccinated
what's the game plan it's a huge huge
huge undertaking but dennis vaccine has
a longer shelf life and lives longer at
room temperature
that could make vaccination a much
quicker and easier prospect
but for many families they still face a
difficult few months
living with a virus that has changed
impacted
and taken so many lives alan fisher al
jazeera
at the white house